Traditional Chinese doctors go into
people's houses to diagnose why it is
that someone in that house of suffering
and they walk in and they think there's
too much order here.
I've been in houses like that.
That's a house where all the furniture
is covered with plastic.
That's a house where if you put a glass
on a wooden table,
that mistress of the house runs over
with the coaster,
slips it under immediately and gives you
a dirty look.
That's a place where the children never
play in the living room.
That's a place where the lines in the
carpet or vacuum so precisely that
they're actually parallel.
That's a place where there's so much
order that no one can survive because
the person who runs the house as a
tyrant and then anyone who's sick in
that house is sick because they're
suffering from an excess of order and
then you can walk into a house that's
completely different and you can even
see this in your own room if you want.
Everything's in complete disarray.
You can't even look at that place.
You're sick the moment you cross the
threshold because everywhere you look,
there's parts of an transforms,
chaos yelling to you,
do something about this loser.